[Music]
give health to cristián cáceres with his
previous information from news now in
spanish families who are in
need of food can go to the
food delivery today friday at
craig range park the
food distribution is possible thanks to commissioner
william  kuri and the culinary academy
this event will start at 8
am and will last until 1 pm
and tomorrow saturday is national
medicine return day so you can
prevent addiction or
overdose deaths by turning in
expired medications from your cupboard  or just the
ones you no longer need there are
plenty of places to dispose of these
including several police stations
around the valley this event is
from 10am to 2pm
and i say it has more announcements it will be opening
three theaters today  these are
located at boulder station green valley
ranch and sunset station fully
available to the general public will
continue to be honored  The
health and safety protocols established by the
federal authorities to prevent the
spread of the virus and today will be a
sunny and pleasant day with temperatures
reaching 80 degrees
some winds will return to the valley for Saturday
and Sunday with some clouds
rain is forecast for  on sunday
night i came up from monday i am cristian
cáceres with his brief informative news
now in spanish good day
[Music]